I think it's innate I think we're all
curious so it's hard for me to say that
it's something we have to teach it's
something that we have to support and
something that we have to let grow and
Thrive that's why all kids they they are
adventurous I really don't think the big
problem is somehow teaching kids how to
be curious I think it's somehow
stimulating them to be curious and an
effective and positive way Barry barish
welcome back to the into the impossible
podcast it's your third time on the on
the show thank you so much for doing
this hi Brian good you're one of our uh
audience's most favorite favorite guest
for many reasons and very special to me
and uh influence on my life and career
and actually the progenitor in some
sense of my second book called into the
impossible uh think like a Nobel Prize
winner which you did honor Me by writing
the forward to that book the second the
second book and since you've been on the
show uh the first time in 2020 when the
kind of inciting incident that will'll
get to led to the creation of this book
um I've added a new feature to my to my
episodes where I ask authors of books to
help me and the audience judge their
books by their covers which Oh by their
covers you're never supposed to do that
right don't judge a book by but what
else do you have to go on right there's
there's almost no information especially
if it's somebody you know that's a
relatively unknown author so an author
spent a lot of time ruminating about you
know what to call the book and so forth
but um I thought we'd play you know we
we' play that same game even though you
didn't write this book but your name is
on the front um so when we uh talked
first um it was actually the second or
third time we had ever met um we we
spoke about this notion that it's very
common in science called the impostor
syndrome and I remember you know clearly
as day and I told my wife that I just
couldn't believe that we closed out the
interview and I asked you as I asked all
my guests as well um what advice you'd
give to your former self and you
basically said you know to kind of get
over the impostor syndrome and I often
think I'm not good enough to have the
impostor syndrome but uh but I was blown
away and I said Barry you won the Nobel
Prize and you said you still have it
maybe you could recount a little bit of
that uh that that uh sentiment that you
expressed originally well I think
anybody if they actually think about it
has it I I Happ been to have a
psychoanalyst for a wife so I can't
avoid kind of the self-reflection that
that uh makes it maybe more evident than
than otherwise but no matter what you're
I think anybody is in company where
people are
um have more ability or whatever you're
talking about than you do and I don't
remember what I said in the in the early
one but the the image that comes to my
mind was actually at the office of the
foundation for the Nobel Prize did did I
talk about that yeah that's what I'd
like yeah I'd love to and that was the
so I'll just repeat it in a few seconds
and and that was you go and you know
there's all this excitement every makes
you feel like you're 10 feet tall
through a week of celebration for the
Nobel Prize and at the end you go to
collect your check and uh sign the book
and get your uh the portrait that they
use in the as the official portrait in
the uh Foundation offices which aren't
very you know fancy or anything it's
just a set of offices uh uh in a a
nondescript building in Stockholm and so
you go and you go through all this stuff
they take your picture and so forth and
eventually they they say oh but you also
have to sign this book and they pull out
this little book it's nondescript it's
more nondescript than yours it doesn't
as I remember it didn't have much of a
cover maybe it's a leather cover do this
segment and they opened to a page that
had nothing on it uh because of the fact
that uh uh in nobel's will will physics
is first so physics is the first one to
get it and probably the first one in the
office I and my name starts with B so I
must have been the first one there was
they opened this book to a blank page
and the top said uh 2017 they just said
sign your name it's okay uh I signed my
name and then I didn't know what to do
so I page backwards and then you see the
names of all the people you idolized in
your life uh you know Einstein finan
blah blah blah and uh if that isn't a
moment when you feel like you don't
belong which is kind of the D
dramatization of this syndrome then uh
you know something's wrong with you I
think so so I think it's a it's a
feature that we all have and should just
be aware of it it shouldn't stop you
from anything it's true that you should
be aware that you're not uniquely
because nobody is better than everybody
else in the world at everything in the
world so the fact that you can do some
things better than others and other
things better and that you have some
real perspective on yourself shouldn't
make you feel like an inferior person
but I think everybody should have some
has should have or else are unaware of
it some semblance of this syndrome so
yeah I always find it tough to strike
balances in life between you know
extremes it's always so easy to fall
into extremes and that's why there's so
much polarization in politics and even
in science but to kind of go down that
Middle Road of being humble on the one
hand as you say but also you know you
need to have a little bit of swagger to
feel that you can accomplish something
that we set out to do a scientist
because it's so ambitious right I mean
oh I think you need a lot of swagger
having Swagger is not orthogonal
or having some sense inside yourself of
your own limitations and your own self
not being better than everybody at
everything it's just I don't think those
are contradictory at all I think to
accomplish something you need to have a
a spirit of gambling you need to have a
a spirit of Adventure you need to have a
Swagger and you need to be willing to
fail and probably that fourth one's the
most important the other revealing thing
that you kind of struck me with like a
thunderbolt the first couple times we
spoke was this notion of of curiosity
being the driving fact
and you highlighted something which I
you know kind of GL glanced over glossed
over whatever you know that there are
all these negative associations with
curiosity yeah uh can you speak why do
you think that is if it's such a valued
component of the and unique to Human
Experience why is it why is it sort of
spoken of in cautionary terms that's
really a good question and I don't have
my wife would have a better answer I
think I think probably somewhat
psychological I think it has to do with
us trying trying to from a young age
have structure and feeling how important
it is for kids to have structure but yet
kids are adventurous so I think probably
the the time period that I picked on
because it's what I think is more or
less where it's dramatic is a kid that
gets to be capable of doing a lot maybe
a pre-teen kid a kid between five and 12
where the kid has a lot of Natural
Curiosity is very adventurous is hard to
contain and yet we have um parents who
try to discipline them and then schools
who put them in a uh cage and curiosity
and following curiosity is fits into
this you know adventurous spirit that
young kid has I I think it's really to
try to feel we have to make kids grow up
and have structure and unfortunately uh
it that's true for parts of growing up
but it's got to be tempered in ways and
somehow having enough sophistication to
let kids pursue curiosity while they
maybe don't you know wreck something in
the house or other things that you
control them is is an art that parents
need to be better at and especially
schools where where we really do
emphasize the discipline and and
basically kill the Curiosity and that to
me is uh something fortunately for me I
avoid it and that it could easily have
happened to me as others it just
happened I escaped and still have that
and and probably you did and certain
others but I think a lot of uh adults
have basically limited themselves
because their discipline of the system
schools could be change and parents have
limited them them in their way they
approaching and also you know you
mentioned the word art you know there's
an art to Parenting there's an art to
being a graduate student adviser there's
an art to being you know a teacher a TA
of of undergraduates if you are
graduates and I guess the thing you know
I've studied you know kind of uh meta
scientific you know people that study
the habits of scientists the sociology
of scientists which which you remarked
on uh at one point with uh in our
conversations uh but I guess the
question I have is you know I think it
was meron or somebody like him who said
you know like if Einstein didn't come up
with relativity you know someone else
would have whereas you know the Mona
Lisa if if you know if it wasn't painted
you know uh as it was it wouldn't have
just spontaneously come about in exactly
the same way maybe something of equal
Beauty I mean you could say the scream
or who knows but do you think that's
it's possible to teach you know uh art
let's say as an artist I don't know that
I believe you can teach someone who has
no ability to be an artist like I have
no ability to play music I can hardly
play Spotify on my phone right uh but
and I don't think think I could be
taught to play music but I know I was
taught to be a physicist by mentors and
folks like you and and I endeavored to
do that with my do you think that
science and art are different cultures
as as you know Lewis or others used to
call it are are fundamentally can you
teach someone to be a curious
imaginative scientific thinker who may
not innately be predisposed in that
direction I think it's inate I think
we're all curious so it's hard for me to
say that it's something we have to teach
it's something that we have to uh
support and something that we have to
let grow and Thrive I think it's built
into that's why all kids they they are
adventurous I I really don't think the
big problem is
somehow teaching kids how to be curious
I think it's somehow stimulating them to
be curious in a in a an effective and
positive way when I uh think back about
you know kind of the things that drive
me and my career now I seem to be much
more kind of UNIF focused on on
exploring the cosmic microwave
background and and finding it you know
kind of all consuming and when I look at
you you were obviously at many points in
your life focused on a single project
but how did you have this the the
discipline the sense the kind of you
know um uh confidence to Pivot as you
did several times in your career to make
outstanding and tremendous contributions
is there is there a point when you
realize it's time for me to to make it
change uh when I spoke to Ray Weiss I'll
just say your colleague and and fellow
Noel laurat um from ligo you he said it
when it stops being fun
yeah you agree with that well that
that's a piece of it I I think as a
scientist theorists are good at it
because there's not much overhead
experiment what I mean good at changing
okay they can go throw it in the waste
basket and take on another problem and
what have they lost not very much so
somebody could have stimulated them for
us there's more of a balance you've got
a big investment in something and I
think it's maybe a little more like an
artist when do they finish a painting
and move on to the next one uh there's
no there's no defined way to define when
a painting is done and when you look at
the variety of paintings some are very
sketchy some are very very detailed
warhall said in fact you know great art
is never finished it's just abandoned
yeah yeah okay stopped I think Picasso
was very very good and articulate about
the fact that you have to let it be
you've done it it's done you move on and
somehow for experimentalists we have a a
big investment like somebody that did a
very detailed uh painting and uh there
is an art I don't think you can learn to
do it an art to know when you're done as
yourself and when to move on and how to
move on and where to move move on and
somehow it's something
I've kind
of developed but it has it had
maybe was a not a complicated thing
maybe because of my personality I I not
I'm not really uh set where I do
something in a particular way and have
to get to some end but but you also
don't want to quit something too early
uh I don't know as a as a
experimental physicist I think uh it's
maybe a little bit like I criticize gr
School teachers I think we're we are
pretty bad in our education and the
course that I teach here at Riverside
and teach U we'll teach at Stonybrook
next fall is aimed at a problem that I
I've always felt was there and that is
in graduate school in fact it was the
reason why I started doing this teaching
teaching in in graduate school we're
very good at teaching theorists about
physics and then they go out in the
world and they're very good at crumpling
paper or the good ones and moving on to
another problem experimental graduate
students we tend to it's it's hard you
have to learn techniques and you have to
do a lot of very hard boring work in a
laboratory and then you have to do
something that's publishable and blah
blah blah and so uh graduate students
come
into UCSD or here or wherever and they
have taken courses and a lot of things
and then they start to go to work for
somebody and as they proceed through
Graduate School uh they become narrower
and narrower but deeper at what they're
doing and narrower and narrower and it's
very common for too common for a
graduate student to get their degree and
basically continue on the same
track uh I I contend that there's
nothing fundamental that make that
fundamental fundamental that that
restricts experimentalists from moving
from one area to another I mean I've
done it not because there's something
very special about me that uh any more
than theorist there's more of an
overhead you can't crumple a paper you
have investment that has may have uh uh
equipment and money and so forth so it's
got to be somewhat more deliberate but I
think still as a research scientist you
should be doing not something because
you have equipment or you have knowledge
in a particular area but because it's
going to move science forward the most
and so at some point
um a different science problem than what
than you've been working on may be more
uh A A Better Way in terms of a product
to
to invest your time energy and effort
and uh I I think there's just there's
overhead in doing it but it's never been
one that's constrained me I mean the
overhead mostly is the system you know
you you a university hires people in
certain areas when you go into another
area it screws up their bookkeeping kind
of they don't like that uh the your you
have uh build a certain trust and
ability to get funding and a certain by
a certain uh funding agency but it's not
just the funding agency it's a subpart
that does the feeli that you're doing so
when you switch you have to so but these
are all you were able to get funding the
first time you you're able to convince
your physics department of what you did
the first time so the fact that you
change it's not a it's never been a big
big issue I think uh so and I think it
also to be honest with you it keeps you
young it keeps you going to change uh
and do other things so to me uh uh it's
not a it's it's a natural way to do
things and we don't do are we don't do a
good job of creating products that have
that mentality my thumb is very busy
right now holding up good old Albert but
if yours is free please go ahead and hit
that like button and don't forget to
subscribe it really helps us with the
algorithm you use the word product but I
guess I would
say what should you know what what is
the obligation of the student you know
obviously we feel a lot uh you're a
product of the University of California
system newcal Berkeley we maybe get to
that later on um but what are
responsibilities of a student let me ask
it specifically what is the bare minimum
what that a an experimental student grad
student what should he or she know about
Theory and what is the obligation of a
theoretical graduate student to un you
know me specializing in theoretical
astrophysics or theoretical physics what
should he or she know about experimental
physics what are the obligations on the
student is the right word obligations
are are the best way to Be an Effective
scientist that's that's the L so so let
me just change to be
effective I think uh like all these
questions if you take the extremes
there's no real answer if you take
theorists that are very mathematically
oriented and their their uh contribution
to physics maybe in moving the
fundamental theoretical tools and ideas
forward maybe don't need to really
understand much about interferometry and
how ligo works or about a MB experiment
right uh other than the what the maybe
what the acronym means or something uh
and and on the other hand very very
technical experimental students maybe
don't need to understand anything about
strength Theory and so I think it's
really the body of us that are more uh
in between any theorist that is doing
theory that might be testable so not
String Theory which so far isn't n
testable uh but experiments that it's
testable is a better theorist if they
have some sense what is what is testable
when they do it what it takes to be
testable and maybe they're more enriched
also by understanding how uh experiment
validates Theory or maybe leads theory
in some cases because of what uh what
they found and then we can go the
reverse and that is experimentalists
unless they're totally uh technologists
they're develop in you know the next
laser for ligo or something uh are
better off if they even if they're
developing the fancy Optics that we need
in the upgrade that we're presently
doing to to ligo the end the what's
going to come out of that is better
sensitivity to see further out in the
universe and some sense of what that
will enable I think is enriching mhm it
should go beyond that it shouldn't just
be more is better shouldn't just be
what's your what's the product of your
own research you know that I see but um
maybe
be uh as a trained experimental
physicist to be able to appreciate if
they're in working in ligo to be able to
appreciate CMB and so forth because it's
basically understandable and so forth so
as a scientist I think at some level to
be able to understand and communicate
and and know that enables them to not be
then in order to be practicing it's fine
to be in Lio and be an experimentalist
it is a theory but to not have your eyes
open broader means you're again
following this path that maybe you
shouldn't be on your whole life yeah
yeah and I definitely think there are
aspects of the experimental method that
can be useful to a theorist trying ideas
doing thought experiments obviously you
know Einstein didn't spend much time in
the lab he has a few patents as you know
but but he uh he didn't spend much time
but he is master and is extremely well
known for gunkan Thought experiments and
and thinking about those and and what
popper called decisive experiments and
how they could not prove a theory but
falsify it right and so you mentioned
string theory and I and I can't you know
help but but kind of pivot on this
expertise that you've gleaned over your
career in in in classical gravity and
wondering because we've never talked
about it what are your perspectives on
the possibility the probability that
we'll ever have a quantum theory of
gravity Ah that's a really good question
and I wish I knew the answer but I'll
just tell you my my belief right now you
know I'm old enough I've watched 50
years or something of people theorist
trying to bring these two Fields
together uh it it's been it's been a
very strong uh maybe slightly Fringe
because they haven't made progress but
uh there there's the attempts to do
quantum gravity has been going on for 50
years and basically haven't succeeded
right okay so um my
uh sense is that like like other areas
of physics what's the problem is that
they're working in a vacuum if you want
they're working without the clues that
you need to actually find your way that
in physics we need some sort of Clues
and the problem is that
uh most of the physics that we do the
Forefront physics now is very deep very
good but it's absolutely in one area or
the other whether it's gravitational
waves where you know we're doing general
relativity and maybe we'll see some
violations of Einstein's general
relativity and that'll give us some clue
But but so far we haven't but we're
doing something that's pursuing general
relativity and if you go to CERN they're
basically looking at the shortest and
shortest distances which is where
Quantum field theory is the king and
does things we need to find somewhere
where you need both um the science that
general relativity is trying to describe
and the science that Quantum field
Theory or or quantum physics at Short
distances is trying to Define we don't
have that at the present time but I
could imagine places past our lifetime
maybe um and one is the very early
universe so the very early Universe
needs to be able to explain both uh you
know how we made particles why there's
more particles than antiparticles uh and
all the um relativistic effects that
happen in the very early universe so if
we could really explore the early
Universe maybe someday with
gravitational waves or some other way
but the true early universe that would
be a a laboratory where you have to
satisfy both things the same is true of
uh black holes so if we could actually
study the physics inside of black holes
which we don't can't do now uh you have
to preserve all the quantum numbers all
the things that we treasure in quantum
physics and you have to obey the rules
of general relativity we have to find a
laboratory where both things are
satisfied and and then get the clues I
think to do this uh unfortunately we
don't have I don't know of anything
right now that we're close to being able
to do that and so the experimentalists
are failing to provide the information
that would give us the ability to bring
it together so it's not just a theorists
are failing because they I think they're
failing because not because of the lack
of tools they have different ideas but
but for to a large extent because they
don't have the experimental hints or
clues or things that they have to
condition and I can imagine There Are
Places I gave two examples but but maybe
there's other places but what we have to
find is places where uh where you need
both together and that's hard because
one tends to work at very short
distances the other at long distances
and high velocity so I can't resist
asking you this question so you're an
experimentalist you're you know known
for tremendous contribution in many
fields but most recently with ligo and
the study of black holes um let's say
you reach that biblical age of
120 uh you've accomplished everything uh
you're about to enter the the the
promised land which for you would be you
know uh these these accomplishments I
want to ask you if you had a a one-way
ticket to visit a black hole would you
take it at 120 so you've got many many
years you should live and be well but
you're about to reach that age you got a
letter from God saying your time is up
do you take that trip
no why not I I don't personalize the
science that I do enough to to do that
there's there's things I'd like to do
before I died uh you know I'd have but
it wouldn't be to go to a black hole
would you I I would I would if I if I
again if I had lived that long Lifetime
and and gotten to that that advanced age
you know Moses didn't get into the
promised land and this is my opportunity
I would I would um to want to understand
what it's like and by the way you
wouldn't feel any pain I I've got
another letter from God that says you
wouldn't feel any pain a
spaghettification or as my four-year-old
calls it
posez uh but uh but to see it and to
experience and this brings up you know I
had this opportunity to speak to a
philosopher of science recently um from
Rice University and and we had a great
conversation but at the end of it I was
left really um with kind of a
existential crisis because essentially
everything that he said and that I
mostly agreed with it's all perception
uh you know even an experimental dial we
we'll read something that's just a
translation into a voltage or an
amplitude or um and so we never directly
experience Sensations or or the true
reality we have proxies and and I guess
the ultimate you know kind of removal of
those is experiential as you said you're
not emotional maybe I'm more emotional
uh and so I would like to see it because
you know in a certain sense there's that
experiential opportunity obviously this
is not likely to happen Disney's not
likely to make you know journey to a
black hole anytime soon in reality but
um but this notion I want to ask you I
felt exasperated by talking to this
wonderful man brilliant Professor but
the sense that like there is almost no
reality because everything is an
interpretation of of uh electrical
signals that we perceive through our
sensors that get processed through other
chemical nodes and this fat and you know
cellular based computer on our shoulders
and I got very exasperated by it because
it basically said you can't really
experience anything it's or that all
experience is is almost elcer um and so
I I feel like our job as experimentalist
is to make as Galileo said you know
measure what's measurable and make
measurable what is not yet so but do you
ever feel like you know what we're doing
is is is only an approximation of
reality or do you does do things like
that not not really trouble you well I I
can relate to it but it's I think we're
a little different and and that I I what
I would say is that maybe I'm going to
say the wrong thing but that you
personalize your science much more than
I do if I want to go to a black hole my
why don't I do it instrumentally and I
wish it would happened during my 120
years that we can actually get inside of
a black hole and do what we we're
talking about but I would be feel very
satisfied by the fact that we built an
instrument that could do it or and
developed the techniques uh not that I
personally was transported in so I could
look and and see so I I I I haven't I
maybe I maybe I'm a little jealous of
you actually that I think it it's a nice
feature to be able to personalize what
you do with yourself and I think you
have the the I think it's a good thing
you have the feature that you are
personalizing uh in that image and
probably in in personality in the
science you do more than I do I kind of
wish I did it would be more fun well
it's one thing you can end I mean as my
colleague said you you should have fun
yeah and that's what science is about
and I think it's hard to have fun if you
don't personalize so I think I think you
have a capability you could uh exploit
kind of it can be frustrated but having
trying to have fun is frustrating
sometimes too so you do things so it's
got the human emotions I think I detach
my human emotions more from my science
than uh than you do probably and I don't
know that that's a good thing it's a
personality yeah it's a personality
thing to be sure I I was really prompted
by that uh experience at a friend of
mine Peter D amandes um who's a medical
doctor a futurist and and so author and
he was the medical doctor who certified
Steven Hawking to take the zero gravity
flight yeah and in the flight you know
Steven's face was you know purposely
contorted because he couldn't really
smile in this way and floating around in
zero gravity was just this this
highlight he and and Eric FY as at UC s
as well uh they coordinated this trip
for him and it just made me think like
if he was that pleased flying on a you
know on a A dc9 or whatever it was you
know all the more so flying on you know
Kip Thorn's Interstellar you know
traveling device to to some black hole
or something like that but pivoting now
back to back to Earth um I I always find
that you know people are fascinated with
their origin stories uh and and and so
to speak and you are a product of the
University of California I wonder if we
could briefly recapitulate
uh the the the kind of early exposure
that you had as as a young student at
Cal and and how you know that maybe has
carried lessons that maybe or maybe not
still exist to this day with the way
that you teach and mentor and practice
science so just to say I I didn't uh
really get interested in science until
almost uh end of High School uh I was
thought I was going to be a writer I
think I said that but so I the closest I
and I came from parents who didn't go to
college so I had a little guidance uh
and I decided I had to do something so I
applied to engineering schools those
were UCLA for me it was uh the the
public education system and it was
either UCLA or Berkeley those were the
two schools at the time and you had to
take an exam to go in engineering and I
uh chose Berkeley I got into both and I
went to Berkeley and I took uh usual
freshman courses and it was I didn't
particularly respond to engineering
which I'll forget for now but I did
respond it turns out to the fact that I
had uh a freshman physics where I was
exposed at least secondarily because it
was a freshman Physics course which is
kind of boring things to the fact that
they were discovering a lot of new
articles and so forth up at the
radiation lab and uh in particular the
instructor I had was Owen Chamberlain
who got the Nobel Prize for discovering
the antiproton he had discovered the
antiproton before I was a student but
didn't yet have the Nobel Prize at that
point and uh it was really the
inspiration of him who I never got to
know really well it's just I was a young
student but it was looking at Owen
Chamberlain that that inspired me to at
least change fields into physics and uh
and again it was through him that I got
into research even though he did nothing
for me in research uh he was he I was
a u a very good student so I didn't have
to I had extra time and he suggested I
get into some research which was
uncommon in those days now we push our
students to get into research as
undergrads yeah and so I uh
uh signed up for some research units
with uh Chamberlain
and he was at the radiation laboratory
which was a hike up the hill now there's
a shuttle M that goes back and for easy
there was a hi yeah and uh I'd go up the
hill and on I don't know Wednesday
afternoons or something when I was
supposed to do my research units and he
was too busy for me which
was not nothing to do do with me but but
it was there was a big overhead in going
up the hill so I'd wander around and the
the big accelerator at that time was the
bevatron you could go anywhere almost
then they didn't have as much radiation
uh safety things yeah but the bevatron
was kind of inhibiting for me and u a
young kid wandering around and I
wandered up to the other cyclotrons and
so forth and met people learned how to
do all that stuff and that's kind of
what captured me it was it was open it
was fun and it was uh all a new world
yeah yeah nowadays you know you not only
can't go wandering through the
cyclotrons but even the chemistry sets
you get for your kids have you know
baking soda and vinegar and no radium
like they did when I was a kid yeah
we've really neutered a lot of what uh
the exposure that kids get to explore
their curiosity you know safety is sort
of a trumped uh trumped um you know
exploration but you know they're they
are good aspects of it I our mutual
friend Gary Sanders talks about you know
people that would go into the beam line
and and they would look to see inside
the cycl see if the beam is operating uh
with their eyes and uh thank God those
those things don't happen anymore but
when we look at the University of
California obviously this is produced in
in part with the UN ucv the best
Production Studios in the world and uh
we have the best students I feel in in
on the planet as well um looking back
you said you know what advice you'd give
to yourself um regarding you know kind
of your your psychological perspective
in a previous show but I want to ask now
scientifically you're starting grad
school take you back to Berkeley um back
uh when you started grad school is there
something else that you would be
fascinated with if you were starting off
today um um you know a lot of the lwh
hanging fruit you know we never have a
term for high hanging fruit I don't know
what it is but I I feel like my son
asked me recently you know what what's
science going to be like in 2050 and and
I felt like um which will be maybe the
final question we'll talk about
artificial intelligence and computerated
physics but but uh we'll get to that in
a moment but I sort of suggested that
maybe it'll be uh just as ambitious but
the discoveries might be smaller in a
certain sense I don't know if you agree
with that but what would you do now as
an incoming grad student at Cal or or
you know a student a young student at
Cal what would you be studying what
would you be fasc bu let me start with
physics and then maybe go broader so so
so first how's it different to be a grad
student in physics like I was uh
compared to now
and how would you how might you approach
it differently when I was a grad student
I think I was really fortunate to be in
a place where there was uh they
developed all these World leading
facilities uh that I could learn about
and be part of but actually doing
something uh was different than now so
you had and know so they so great they
they were do there was a facility they
were able to do new things uh and but I
had to do learn how to be a physicist
and do physics at that point it really
when I was a student you had to conceive
of and build uh new instrumentation like
you're doing for your thing but as a
grad student I mean basically that's
what you did as a young student you
basically had to be uh had to build
something that somebody hadn't to build
electronics that would be faster to do
something to be able to do something
somebody hadn't done uh I think that's
not the problem facing an experimental
student today I think it's just almost
flipped and that is that the problem was
physics at that time was ahead of
instrumentation and so um you had to
build new instrumentation and then the
physics followed new instrumentation
before me with things like a bubble
chamber uh when I was there we were just
creating the electronics to do accurate
time of flight that particles would go
along you do accurate time of flight
then you could tell the difference
between a peson and a Kon or a proton
because the heavier ones went slower and
you could distinguish them by doing time
of flight and you had to make fast
Electronics to do that but you couldn't
go buy it you had to build it and so the
idea was there and you build it today I
think the problem is different if you if
you think of the technology that you
need to um
improve uh uh an experiment for for CERN
the calorimetry or ligo or other things
not the big ones that are very very
engineered but but anything else there's
a the wealth
of techniques and and technology that
hasn't yet been applied to physics so I
think the cleverest and most successful
students of today that will stand out in
the ways that say I've been fortunate to
stand out have the will have the ability
to be the first to use techniques that
have been developed elsewhere I don't
care whether we talk about machine
learning which is underused in physics
and astronomy compared to other things
for a reason that we use statistics to
do our analysis to determine what's
right or wrong and statistics and
machine learning are kind of orthogonal
because it's a black box but machine
learning can do things very well so how
to apply machine learning to help you or
um um developed Electronics or other
other things the outside world has
developed faster than we've developed I
remember when silicon detectors were
first developed for uh particle physics
detectors and they're the most precise
way to track a a a particle and that's
basically using uh something that makes
uh uh micro electronics and you do on uh
and the first ones were used in particle
physics uh they had the limitation they
weren't radiation hard so you put them
around the beam and they wouldn't last
very long and the early experiments even
the ones done at at fmy lab uh had a lot
of trouble
employing these tracking detectors which
were 10 times more accurate than the
tracking detectors we have individual
wires and so forth and the first time it
ever was done accurately enough was
developed by particle physicists and
they discovered the
top and the discovery of the top at at
fmab was the last experiment done on an
accelerator not because you know the
accelerator got better it was because
they had developed the technology of
silicon which couldn't be done earlier
now the outside world is 100 times
better at silicon than we are and so
there's a lot of places where the
technology has moved in the outside to
be better so uh it seems to me uh if I
were a young starting graduate student
now I would learn as much as I could
about technology and how I can answer a
questions now that people couldn't a
decade ago uh because of the
technological advances so I think the T
turned in a sense of for experimental
so I said maybe for the final uh set of
questions we hear a lot about artificial
intelligence machine learning you
mentioned but they're they're they're
distinct but um there's been not a small
amount of discussion about whether or
not you could make an artificially
intelligent physicist basically uh to
explore data sets or to actually Divine
the laws of of physics and even
retrodict laws that we already know
about and maybe predict new laws that we
don't have have yet uh uh knowledge on I
want to ask you um this this quote from
Einstein you're the man who gave you
impostor syndrome uh later on in life
despite winning a Nobel Prize and many
other accolades he said uh do you
remember he said that the happiest
thought of his life was that an observer
in freef Fall Would experience no
gravitational field and he called that
the happiest thought now and I always
say to people that make these claims
like my friend Max tegmark and and
others that we're going to have
artificial Ein AI e AE you know Einstein
how can a computer first of all uh
really replicate that because it
wouldn't have a sensation of freef fall
because it doesn't have the visceral
sensation a and then B what would
happiness mean to it now maybe a
computer would have some other metric
that it could optimize that we could
call happiness but it seems to me what
led Einstein to the you equivalence
principle and the form that he used to
derive the laws of general relativity
that you employed with your colleagues
are you sanguin about that do you feel
like there will be artificial Einstein
and and U and uh and Kip thorns and so
forth or do you think that there'll be
AIDS like we use you know to go shopping
and to you know find the the best thing
to watch on Netflix or uctv I can only
talk about the what I call the finite
future what I can see and what I can't
uh I think AI can't do what Einstein was
talking about or uh an element of what
we all do and that is that as good as
the fact that it's
getting great at playing chess go um
analyzing data if it's the right if you
have the right uh uh uh kind of
data uh better than us it's synthesizing
a lot of data faster and so forth it
basically has made no progress at all in
reasoning and reasoning is the word I
would use reasoning it seems to me
decision making and reasoning which is
not made from doing an analysis of facts
but comes from somewhere else is the
heart of what creates these other
emotions it's the thing that the fact
that he reasoned what it was like to be
in an
elevator is what then gave him the
emotion of happiness but the fact is the
reasoning that he did could you
duplicate that not the happiness right
but the reasoning itself and there's no
progress in that at all AI doesn't do
that right and so I think as long as and
I don't Envision how it can it's
something that's in our brains that
humans have that uh I don't what we
don't have any we haven't made any
progress in being able to replicate or
understand we have an ability to I me
you can't capture it in one word but the
word I would use is reasoning not
happiness is an emotion so no I don't
think so I think we're unique as our
brains someday
we'll maybe understand what
Consciousness is and and what something
like reasoning is how we make decisions
based on not just an analytical thing
and choices and so forth is a very
human human element it's basically not
something that scientists whether
physicists or anybody else really
understands and so I don't see it uh
duplicated well it's good to know we'll
have job security as physicists that but
as I said that's true our vision how
long we can see but that's probably
through our lifetimes anyway I
appreciate your tremendous Vision Barry
as as usual uh being so generous with
your time and with your uh inspiration
and mentorship not just to me but to
Millions around the world and I I wish
you many many years until I can convince
you to come along on the trip to the
black holes Event Horizon that'll be for
another time thank you so much bar okay
thank you